voilà alors on parlait évidemment des
pratiques à risque la pratique à risque
au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est d'être
simplement non porteurs d'un préservatif
c'est ça ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
les pratiques à risque maintenant il n'y
a plus de groupe à risque et la
contamination bien évidemment ne peut
s'éviter que emportant un préservatif et
les autres contaminations
enfin les autres les autres pratiques
c'est à dire le baiser le serment demain
etc etc on le répétera jamais assez ne
ne contiennent pas pour quelque chose
je vais enfin c'est une bêtise c'est un
truc bête que j'ai envie de faire depuis
depuis le début parce que après tout on
est là pour s'unir
les séropositifs les pas séropositif les
homosexuels est homosexuel et j'ai envie
de faire un truc con j'ai envie
d'embrasser le monsieur que derrière moi
sur la bouche
voilà est ce qu il a de la chance
monsieur
car elle et je suis sûr que dans tout
endroit aura plusieurs dégâts l'euro la
démago et les ruiner tout ça c'est juste
qu'ils ont envie de changer uniquement
pour que tout le monde comprenne enfin
que je ne suis pas contagieux je suis
exigeante
éventuellement ces transmissibles pierre